[Music]
originally this lien was council-owned
but at the time it was proposed for
forestry at the time the community got
together and said that's the prefer it
to be as a native receive so since then
we've been developing and partnership
with a group of residents so no silver
stream reserve advisory group we've had
an event from weekend as well we've also
had massive support from the main house
so I've been attending all of the
planting days that we do which is really
cold to have always got a presence and
are really up stead of what we're doing
we're squeezing it to make sure that and
we can pull also out when we pull it
exactly school they're great they come
down on a regular basis and they love
coming down Silverstream I'm sure part
of the appeal is working with dead a
group of kids made up that they were you
know going to be part of the Duke
victory and they had a little chain and
workers going doing different jobs and
here today they were like can we do that
again and we're like you're sure it's
not do it this time it's mulch so yeah
they they love it
you embrace the chaos basically say I
just say my bed at the start and they
say right plants are here tools are here
let's go for it and then we've got what
we've got now we've got a bunch of them
doing the mulch delivery some of them
doing watering others you know going out
of doing making sure all the guards are
fitted properly and things like that so
you get this sort of teamwork and then
you get these really cool initiatives
coming through so yeah you can see that
the future leaders coming through in
that regard as well the community the
ones we see coming through here are so
thrilled to see it being developed and
how things are growing so well so we get
quite a bit of feedback from people now
and it's really fun so we're all
enthusiasts it's great it's beneficial I
mean we if we come here on walks the
kids can see what they've done yeah yeah
I mean it's making place way better like
this ground is pretty stony and levy and
scrubbing so yeah by the end of our own
secret fantastic
[Music]
you